Transcription: Hélène Vernet
Relecteur: eric vautier
Ce soir, je vais vous parler de l'un
des plus gros scandales scientifiques
de ces cent dernières années au moins.
Pour que vous puissiez prendre
la mesure de ce scandale,
je vais commencer
par vous montrer trois photos.
La première photo, la voici.
Il s'agit d'un trou noir.
Le trou noir est l'un des objets
astrophysiques les plus fascinants,
mais peut-être aussi les plus inquiétants,
les plus effrayants de l'univers.
Tout ce qui tombe dedans
est piégé à jamais.
La lumière elle-même ne peut en sortir,
donc il nous semble noir, obscur, sombre.
Leur existence a été prédite
par la théorie d’Einstein,
en 1915, il y a peu près cent ans.
Au début, personne n'y croyait vraiment,
et aujourd'hui, on sait qu'il en existe
dans le centre de quasiment
toutes les galaxies de l'univers.
Ce qui est à l'intérieur,
personne ne sait.
Personne n'y a été voir et je vous
déconseille d'aller y faire un tour.
Aucune théorie n'est aujourd'hui
en mesure d'expliquer
ce qu'il se passe
à l'intérieur des trous noirs.
La deuxième photo, vous voyez,
représente un phénomène
qui n'a rien à voir avec le précédent.
Les esprits les plus éclairés
auront vu des petites ressemblances,
mais cette fois-ci, il s'agit
d'un morceau de matière noire.
La matière noire, on l'appelle ainsi
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est.
On n'a pas trouvé d'autre nom.
On ne la sent pas, on ne la voit pas.
Ce qu'on pense savoir, c'est qu'on en
trouve dans quasiment toutes les galaxies.
Comment ? En regardant la façon
dont les galaxies tournent.
Les galaxies, aujourd'hui,
tournent tellement vite dans l'univers
qu'elles devraient se disloquer.
Prenez une assiette de soupe, faites-la
tourner sur votre table encore plus vite.
Vous allez vite imaginer
que vous aurez un truc
qui ne ressemblerapas tropà une galaxie,
mais la soupe va,
en quelque sorte, se disloquer.
C'est pareil, on devrait observer
la même chose sur les galaxies,
mais, on voit qu'elles
existent, elles sont là.
Alors, les physiciens
ont supposé qu'il existe
une forme de matière,
la matière noire, qui est là, un peu,
pour coller les éléments de la galaxie,
grâce à l'interaction gravitationnelle,
et l'empêcher de se disloquer.
Cette matière noire,
selon nos calculs, aujourd'hui,
représenterait 25 %
du contenu de l'univers.
La troisième photo -
vous êtes maintenant de grands
experts d'astro et de cosmologie -
vous reconnaîtrez ici, l'énergie noire.
(Rires)
L'énergie noire, on en trouve
un peu partout dans l'univers -
ici, dans un amas de galaxies.
Et l'énergie noire, tout comme
son copain la matière noire,
on l'appelle ainsi parce qu'on
ne sait pas ce que c'est.
On ne la voit pas, on ne la sent pas.
Comment on pense savoir
qu'il y a de l'énergie noire ?
Parce qu'il y a vingt ans,
on s'est aperçu que l'univers
grossissait de plus en plus vite.
Si l'univers était un ballon de baudruche,
imaginez que quelqu'un souffle
dedans de plus en plus fort
pour le faire grossir
de plus en plus vite.
Dans cette image, ce quelqu'un
qui insuffle de l'énergie,
c'est précisément ça
qu'on appelle « l'énergie noire ».
Évidemment, il n'y a personne
au bout de l'univers -
peut-être que oui,
mais moi, je ne l'ai pas encore vu -
il n'y a personne qui pousse l'univers,
mais aujourd'hui on le voit
grossir de plus en plus vite
et donc on suppose qu'il existe une forme
d'énergie qui va être l'énergie noire.
Selon nos calculs, l'énergie noire
forme 70 % du contenu de l'univers.
Alors, faisons un petit bilan.
On arrive maintenant
dans une situation où finalement,
le modèle d'univers, c'est celui-ci.
Le petit carré blanc, là-haut,
c'est ce que vous connaissez :
les galaxies, les planètes
à l'intérieur, les étoiles.
On y met aussi les trous noirs
car on sait à peu près ce qu'ils sont,
même si on ne sait pas trop
ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
Tout le reste, 25 % de matière noire,
70 % d'énergie noire,
pour arriver à une situation
où 95 %, on ne sait pas ce que c'est.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez conscience
des moyens, de l'énergie que l'on met,
pour aller comprendre
ce qu'il se passe dans l'univers.
Les moyens, c'est quoi ?
Ce sont les dizaines de milliers
de chercheurs qui bossent
des centaines de milliers d'heures
dans les labos, dans les observatoires,
qui utilisent les outils les plus
puissants, les plus sophistiqués
que l'homme a jamais construits :
accélérateurs de particules,
détecteurs d'ondes gravitationnelles,
des satellites qu'on envoie dans le ciel
pour envoyer plein de télescopes
et avoir des images du ciel.
Tout ça, pour arriver
à la situation où 95 % de l'univers,
eh bien désolé,
on ne sait pas ce que c'est.
(Rires)
Quelle société, qui accepterait ça ?
Qui accepterait autant
de moyens pour ce résultat-là ?
Alors, on va voir les chercheurs,
on leur demande :
« Il se passe quoi, là ? »
« Je ne sais pas, c'est dur, c'est loin
l'univers, tout ça... On n'y arrive pas.
Ce n'est pas comme si on cherchait
une aiguille dans une botte de foin.
Là, c'est la botte de foin
qu'on cherche, carrément. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Une fois qu'on a fait ce constat,
il faut essayer d'aller de l'avant.
Je suis physicien-théoricien.
Avec mes collègues et collaborateurs
dispatchés un peu partout dans le monde,
on élabore des théories
pour essayer de rendre compte
de la nature et de l'existence
de l'énergie noire.
Ce soir, je ne suis pas
peu fier de vous montrer
le résultat et le fruit
de nos dernières découvertes,
et je suis sûr que vous allez voir
avec moi derrière cette équation,
les secrets de l'énergie noire
et de la matière noire.
Cachez votre enthousiasme, c'est vrai.
(Rires)
C'est dingue tout ce qu'on peut
voir derrière cette équation-là.
Nous, on y voit beaucoup de choses.
A mon avis, une équation de ce type
n'est pas loin d'être très proche
d'un tableau de maître,
Van Gogh, « La nuit étoilée ».
Si vous n'avez jamais vu ce tableau-là,
je peux me risquer à le décrire :
un arbre dans la pénombre,
au second plan, un village sous un ciel
un petit peu tourmenté, façon Van Gogh,
des étoiles et un clair de lune.
Si je commence à vous le décrire,
vous allez certainement
visualiser le tableau,
et éventuellement comprendre ce que
Van Gogh a voulu dire à travers lui.
Mais, si vous allez au musée
et que vous voyez « La nuit étoilée »,
l'émotion ressentie
sera sans commune mesure.
Une équation, c'est
peut-être la même chose.
Je vous montre une équation,
je peux essayer de la verbaliser,
vous dire ce qu'il y a derrière,
ce qu'elle signifie.
Si je suis assez bon, vous allez
peut-être percevoir deux ou trois trucs
qui vont vous éclairer
sur la nature de l'énergie noire.
Mais, si vous lisez l'équation
dans le langage mathématique,
si vous la visualisez en quelque sorte,
je vous garantis aussi que l'émotion
et la satisfaction intellectuelle
que vous allez ressentir
seront également sans commune mesure.
A ce titre, certaines équations de la
physique dont vous avez entendu parler,
l'équation d’Einstein
pour l'infiniment grand,
où l'équation de Schrödinger
pour l'infiniment petit,
sont considérées comme de véritables
chefs-d’œuvres de la physique.
Alors notre équation,
franchement, je ne crois pas qu'elle ait
la beauté de l'équation d’Einstein.
Et honnêtement, on n'est pas
encore complètement convaincus
qu'elle va nous éclairer
sur l'énergie noire.
(Rires)
Alors, on va peut-être éviter
d'en rajouter un petit peu plus.
En plus, sérieux, au début,
quand j'ai préparé ce talk,
je me suis dit : « Pas d'équation ! »
Mais, je travaille tous les jours avec,
et je n'ai pas résisté à la tentation
de vous montrer au moins celle-ci.
Je me suis dit aussi :
« Pourquoi leur parler d'énergie
noire et de matière noire ? »
La seule chose qu'on connaisse,
ce sont ces belles images
que je vous ai montrées au début.
On n'a aucune certitude sur
ce que sont énergie et matière noire,
que des hypothèses, que des doutes.
Alors au fond,
peut-être qu'on peut essayer de prendre
un peu de recul sur ces questions-là,
et que la bonne question à poser, c'est :
« Pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'y arrive pas
malgré tous les moyens qu'on se donne,
et pourquoi ce n'est pas
un scandale, bien au contraire ? »
Alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'y arrive pas ?
La réponse, cette fois-ci, je peux
vous la donner, elle est limpide.
C'est juste parce que c'est difficile.
C'est fichtrement difficile !
(Rires)
Donc, on n'y arrive pas,
mais ce n'est pas
parce que c'est difficile
et que la situation
a l'air absurde a priori,
qu'il faut se démotiver et abandonner
la question, bien au contraire.
Et c'est là qu'on touche le thème
de ce soir, l'utopie du physicien.
L'utopie du physicien,
c'est celle de croire
qu'on se dote des outils
qui vont nous permettre de répondre
à toutes les questions qui nous entourent.
Franchement, c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je fais de la physique,
cette envie de comprendre
tout ce qui m'entoure.
Mais en même temps, on sait
très bien que plus on connaîtra,
plus ce sera difficile
de savoir plus, parce qu'à la fin,
les questions qui restent sont toujours
les questions les plus difficiles.
Et dans ce cas-là, il va falloir
redoubler d'imagination.
Il va falloir trouver les idées
les plus farfelues certains diront,
les plus révolutionnaires pour d'autres,
construire des instruments encore plus
forts, plus sophistiqués, plus puissants,
pour aller dénicher la solution,
quelque part entre l'infiniment
grand et l'infiniment petit.
Ces problèmes de l'énergie noire
et de la matière noire
sont de très belles histoires
pour illustrer ce fait.
Il y a cent ans, quand Einstein
est arrivé avec sa théorie,
on pensait avoir sous la main
les outils qui nous permettraient
d'aller sonder tous les coins
et recoins de l'univers.
Et puis là, paf, arrivent
énergie noire et matière noire !
Et là, on ne sait plus.
L'outil dont on pensait pouvoir
tout extraire ne marche plus très bien.
On n'arrive plus vraiment à lui faire dire
ce qu'on voudrait lui faire dire.
Mais, ce n'est pas grave parce que
dans l'histoire de la physique,
on a eu plein de moments comme ceux-ci
où on pensait avoir des théories,
au XIXe siècle par exemple,
qui permettraient de tout savoir
sur tout le monde, sur vous, sur moi,
sur ce qu'on a été dans le passé,
et ce qu'on sera dans le futur, tout !
Et puis, il restait des petits détails
par-ci par- là à comprendre.
Et ces petits détails se sont avérés
de véritables cataclysmes.
Toute la théorie s'est effondrée,
on a reconstruit dessus,
et c'est ainsi que sont nées la mécanique
quantique pour l'infiniment petit
ainsi que la relativité générale
pour l'infiniment grand.
Je ne sais pas si les problèmes
de la matière noire ou de l'énergie noire
vont aboutir à des révolutions
aussi cataclysmiques.
Mais ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'on va tout faire pour y arriver.
Mais, on sait aussi qu'on veut s'approcher
d'une forme de vérité absolue.
La vérité scientifique, la vérité
de tous les jours certainement,
c'est un concept asymptotique.
Plus on s'en approche,
plus il est difficile d'y accéder.
C'est un peu comme le paradoxe
d'Achille et la tortue.
Achille, vous connaissez tous
le personnage de la mythologie grecque,
la tortue, c'est la tortue...
(Rires)
Achille part en retard
dans sa course derrière la tortue.
Il est confiant. Au bout de quelque pas,
il voit l'animal en ligne de mire.
Il se dit : « Aucun problème. »
Il avance, il avance,
et à chaque fois, il reste une distance,
certes petite, certes
de plus en plus petite,
mais une distance qui est toujours là
pour rattraper la tortue.
Plus il avance,
plus ses jambes sont lourdes,
le sol se dérobe comme du sable mouvant.
L'histoire raconte qu'Achille
ne rattrapera jamais la tortue.
Et le physicien le sait,
le scientifique le sait.
Il connaît très bien le sentiment
d’Achille derrière la tortue,
mais il continue, il avance,
parce qu'il rêve de découvrir
des nouveaux mondes.
Et au fond, en physique, en science,
on avance par petits pas.
Quelquefois, on fait des bonds de géant.
Parfois, on recule, on fait marche arrière
peut-être pour prendre de l'élan.
D'autres fois, on avance et puis là,
on se trouve face
à un précipice vertigineux -
l'énergie noire peut-être -
un problème incommensurable...
Il paraît que je n'ai pas
le droit de dépasser. (Rires)
Dans ces cas-là,
soit je saute sur le public,
soit on essaie de construire
de nouvelles routes, de nouveaux ponts,
qui vont nous permettre
d'accéder de l'autre côté de la rive.
Souvent l'Histoire raconte ces ponts
qui ont été construits par un seul homme.
On retient Einstein.
Einstein a construit quasiment
ses propres lois, de nouvelles routes,
qui nous ont permis de sonder,
au sens propre comme au figuré,
tous les coins et recoins de l'univers.
On est parti loin
avec la théorie d’Einstein.
Mais très souvent,
la construction d'un pont scientifique
est une œuvre collective.
Chacun vient, il dépose une brique,
ou quelqu'un d'autre enlève une brique
qui était cassée et ne marchait pas bien.
Un autre va ajouter le ciment
et au final, on arrive à des édifices
qui sont formidables, merveilleux.
Alors peut-être que dans un,
dix, vingt, trente ou cent ans,
l'un de vous, dans cent ans,
sera là et expliquera
comment il a réussi à construire
un pont vers le vaccin contre le sida,
vers le problème
du réchauffement climatique,
vers une solution contre
la pauvreté dans le monde,
vers la conquête de la planète Mars,
ou quelqu'un sera là et nous dira
ce qu'est l'énergie noire.
Si aujourd'hui je suis physicien,
je le dois beaucoup à la curiosité
que beaucoup de mes enseignants,
de mon entourage, ont nourri
au plus profond de moi.
Vouloir savoir et savoir
est une source d'inspiration infinie,
mais ça, ça ne suffit pas.
Il faut aussi accepter ne pas savoir,
accepter d'atteindre ses limites.
Mais cette forme d'ignorance
ne doit pas être une source
de frustration ou d'aigreur.
Elle doit être une source de motivation.
Okay, on connaît 5 % de l'univers,
mais, il reste 95 % à explorer !
Allons-y !TED a mis plein
de fusées à notre disposition.
Ffft ! On s'envole vers l'énergie noire !
Merci.
(Applaudissements)